[Music]
it was a little past midnight when I got
the call asking me to knock doors for
Hillary Clinton
the caller was my friend Jason who was
working on the campaign in Pennsylvania
he wanted me to take time off of my job
to help with the final push why me I
asked him isn't there someone else more
qualified at the time I was serving as a
policy advisor at the White House and
what I was actually wondering was isn't
there someone else less overqualified I
was working on change at scale if I got
this policy done on self-driving cars we
would potentially be saving over 40,000
lives per year and if I took time off of
work I would knock how many doors I also
didn't know the first thing about
talking to a stranger at their front
door what I knew about was policy the
decision seemed obvious I could add more
value right where I was sorry I said but
Jason didn't give up you want to make a
difference come knock doors I didn't
believe him but I went anyway because a
friend had asked and I am so glad that I
did because for a long time I thought
that the way to create change was
top-down and that meant advising
government leaders at McKinsey or
creating policy at the White House not
knocking on doors in Pennsylvania maybe
some of you have a similar view but I
want to talk to you about why bottom-up
change matters too knocking on doors can
change elections change you and change
our world today so what does it mean to
knock on doors knocking on doors is
about getting into a neighborhood and
going door-to-door to talk to voters it
has two primary purposes force waiting
voters and increasing turnout knocking
on doors might feel old school but it
makes sense
think about how you change someone's
mind its face to face through a
relationship built on trust
knocking on doors relies on both of
those strategies for persuading voters
it's also an effective tool for driving
turnout talking to voters can provide
the nudge that they need to actually get
out there and vote on Election Day
I remember the first time I knocked on
doors I thought this works I remember
the woman in Pittsburgh who told me she
wasn't going to vote because she didn't
know where her polling location was just
the kind of information I had on hand at
another home a man with a golden
retriever stood at the door and said he
wasn't going to vote because Hillary had
it in the bag
I showed him the latest polling numbers
and he promised me he'd vote after that
experience I dug into the research and
found out that two decades of studies
have shown that the surest way to change
an election outcome is to have high
quality door knocking talking to voters
and getting out the vote can make all
the difference especially when margins
are tight take Virginia in 2017 a heated
local race between Democrat Shelley
Simmons and Republican David Yancey
ended in a tie they ended up deciding
the winner by pulling a name out of a
hat that one race resulted in
Republicans maintaining control of the
State House that means one vote could
have changed why health care wages
schools look like for the state and not
every election is won by one vote but
every election cycle there are races
with razor thin margins
knocking on doors is also essential for
national victories in 2016 120 million
votes were cast for the presidential
election but just a hundred and seven
thousand of those votes in three states
determine the outcome a hundred and
seven thousand votes to put that in
perspective if each of us at the
Business School had spoken with just a
hundred and twenty five voters which by
the way you can do in one day we would
have spoken with all of them yes
elections feel big and daunting but
ultimately they're won by relatively
small numbers and those small numbers
have huge impact knocking on doors can
also change you let's face it it can be
intimidating to knock on a stranger's
door but we also know that it's in
moments of discomfort that we grow the
most and you'll grow tremendously both
as a leader and as a citizen today our
world is not set up to interact with
people who are different from us instead
of taking public transportation we take
movers instead of going to the movies we
opt for Netflix in bed and when we want
a cup of sugar
we don't go to our neighbors we go to
instacart
knocking doors gets you out of that
bubble no to conversations I've had at
the door have ever been the same as a
result I've practiced and built a range
of skills I have more empathy after
listening to the stories of strangers I
take more risk after rejection after
rejection at the door and I'm much more
comfortable in difficult conversations
after navigating some hostile attitudes
all of those skills translate in a
really real way to the workplace if
you're an entrepreneur you'll be that
much better at uncovering the needs of
your customers if you're an investor
you'll be more persuasive when it comes
to raising money for me as a policy
maker I'm much better at analyzing the
effects of my policies and programs on a
range of citizens outside of my
immediate circle I'm also a more
informed voter well I might not be
personally struggling with access to
health care Thank You Stanford Cardinal
care after a conversation in Virginia
Beach with a woman whose daughter was
struggling with diabetes I have this
window into how healthcare policy
affects lives and why it matters to vote
for it
so knocking on doors doesn't just change
elections it also changes you here at
the Business School my peers often say I
want to make a difference but let me
focus on making it to the top first and
then I'll do a lot with that money power
and position to do a lot of good but
we're at a critical moment right now on
climate change on health care on the
future of our workforce our democratic
processes are crumbling some things
aren't reversible and so we have to
start changing our world today when I
came to campus back in the fall I was
excited to be surrounded by my peers who
were eager to get out there and make a
difference when the 2018 midterm
election rolled around 100 students
expressed interest in getting involved
but on the day that it came down to
actually knocking doors only two other
students showed up the district's we
were knocking in was josh Harder's in
central valley california he won the
election but it was so close it took
them a week to call it our door knocking
made a difference very few of us are
probably going to knock on doors as
full-time job that's likely not the way
that we aspire to change lives change
organizations and change the world but
there isn't a trade-off here you can
pursue your career of top-down change
while still knocking on doors today they
aren't mutually exclusive in fact
they're mutually beneficial we have an
election coming up in 2020 pick a race
it could be something local it could be
for the next president of the United
States and commit to getting into a
neighborhood even if just once and knock
on some doors I'll see you out there
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]